[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it's
time for Echo episode three this is Coy this
is John we don't really have much time we got
to film this right now so leave a like on this
video subscribe and click the notification
Bell thank you so much and pre for helping
us set down these highlights F length through
your watch res sing with your own copy of echo
for super sex rejects over our patreon page we
cover several things SC through the highlights
and watch alongs included I don't even care to
ask you how you guys are doing let's get to it
[Music]
cool Martin scorsi presents he's been
fighting to get into this universe in
the late 1800s Indian country was infested
with dangerous criminals threatening the
safety of the native nations tribes established
their own police force to bring these criminals
to Justice these trip is this like a
lawn Defenders the light Horsemen all
right wow this is fun is this
fun this story of what they
had to endure yeah the style is
fun CG history can be light and
badass it's fun oh my God what do those
gourds ever do to you I love how this is
shot so modern day with cool camera work a
lot of depth of field yeah oo [Music] too
wow cool all right now let's see you do
that with the vibranium Shield or your
hat uhoh but it's in the
name yeah something shouldn't
change ever men are life
takers just produce a baby and then let it
be unto the elements braids are for men it's
right I agree if it wasn't difficult to
do with headphones on I'd tie one right
now you will defeat the
[Music] Predator this a really cool way
to do a backstory an exposition and I like
how much time they take for these things yeah
they're letting everything breathe especially
the openings being the supernatural or past
elements yeah going from the the game and the
last one to this oh man she going to save
the day she going to whoop some ass right
now I think they're chronological too right the
mountain falling the game and then this seem to
[Music]
be
whoa bang
bang some ass tcko this must be
oh she's the ancestor that yeah
beautiful shots whoa we have Ender
full frame here dang and a color fade
in Cory uhoh and some sound design get
[Music]
him aim [Music] true braer
for men take that down at
[Music] once ah just that look
in her eye proud papa she can
shoot nice I like that the sound I didn't
even catch the frame change and the sound
like blending into it that was really cool
I want to say you said frame change it
actually went frame change t t it was
4 by what six as Zack Snider intended
yeah Ah that's a great first shot after that is
that is clever I really like film making is on is
really this and what if have really demonstrated
film making capacity in Marvel more than some
other thing agreed it's called Cinema SC ASI
oh Cinema C the crap I didn't come here to get
laid up by some old res dog like res dogs ah you
used to melt like butter when I talk you Marvel
Spotlight my back kill the mood thought that
might have something to do with it want to
hump she's too much like her father you don't
know that you don't even know her and you do
you haven't seen her any more than I have in the
last 20 years uh water hump you know you two are
exactly alike we are not alike you lost your
daughter what should just swallow your pride
before you lose your granddaughter too I can't
talk to her now I got nothing to say oh you find
something well maybe you shouldn't talk to her
maybe you should just listen for once you know
what it is that I figured out of why I'm so
connected more with the supporting characters
because there's some actual like tension in a
variety of emotion whether that be like fear
and joy there's levels MH or with whenever we cut
to Maya sometimes I feel like it's kind of she's
just little one note being B yeah Zane I promise
you man my is here tonight have already wait for
my call oh trackx Mafia coming to town let's
get bowling alley fight or rolling skate fight
that's meanwhile an evil dead rise
now this is where uh Ben Affleck and
galado had a conversation about steeping wol oh
yeah oh cool they
mean
o oh they tried to warn her get you with
mystical chloroform no this I think she
was really taken no she the spirits the
ancestors are trying to prot Spirits do it
it's fast oh you're going
to have to fight on that leg
now that it is a
blessing
bag read lips can't you guys I'll take care
of it argue in Sign Language guys yes consider
it uhoh oh he's he's he must be maybe he's
not bad maybe not or maybe he's going to do
something treacherous I don't know I hope
not he's in a tough position budy oh no
she's going to be in danger and she's going
to realize how much she cares about her oh
man hello shut up shut up oh boy you guys gonna
make this personal get out of really want to
escape I'll do whatever it takes to skate
oh no we didn't think to lock this door the
delivery door it's after 600 PM no was
supposed to be there thought it was fun
hey hey I tried the front whoa not a good time
pretty busy I like the timing of I won't take
very long I maybe you guys can communicate
in Sign Language there you go there you go
why don't you call me tomorrow the rank's being
um audited by the IRS and I'm just swimming in
paperwork is there anything I can do no no
no I'm good probably shouldn't have deducted
all that mileage on all those pairs of skates
that's clever joke they'll give you 22 cents a
gallon appreciate it I thought these guys were
working for fist they work for for the IRS yeah
yeah that's the twist tracksuit Mafia is
actually Auditors I'm having the hardest
time keeping up with the show you can't
spell Wilson Fisk without the IRS come on
get your firefighting hose yes down dispatch
dispatch oh no there's a third one way to go
Maya the people you care about are in danger
now because of you you're going to realize
this episode that you care Oh is she going to
attach that skate to her left oh my God she's
going to take him on one legged the reunion
you want you should have said hi that shirt
though this better be like in a impactful ass
moment the whole MCU have been waiting for Bonnie
and her to reunite they also can't communicate
because their hands are Ted she could take off her
shoe Morris code sweet the name's B of course of
course like how we just like cut through non not
just woo great shot that's really cool
that's a cool way of using that Trope
of reflection in Mirror another great
example of like a filmmaker like it
feels like planned and storyboarded
whoa whoa not get carried away here
pre-production okay thank you show I needed
this scene with her yeah me Greg Greg me
feeling I wrote you every day for 5 years
a letter she's no gosl they just feel like
sisters yeah yeah it's you got to try not to keep
touch nowadays what did you do Maya brought this
on herself coming home all I did was accelerate
the process you called someone I ain't taking
orders no more not from you I'm taking orders
from someone else with money sometimes he's
got better orders come on Vicky I swear I heard
something it might be loose quickly though some
ADR way she holding that gun yeah the both of them
jeez thank you whoa whoa whoa whoa
don't shoot her if she's dead when
they get here we ain't getting paid hey
eyes on the prize this is our fault we
letting him do the tie in hey hey do not
assum un kill them yeah take them out oh
yeah y'all ain't ready for this come
on [__] they locked it we can't shoot through
the door I think we got to go back in there and
H Tire it's not worth the trouble the door's
locked anyway what is that phone number can
I like climb through like the ceiling like die
hard it a little bit you know what I mean the
window got a plan she's going to pop out she
would have R Bonnie without and can Maya not
read lips I'm sure she can right but whenever
they cut to her perspective and people are
talking it seems like she can't make out what
they're saying you're the guy then yeah I'm
the guy Vicki Vicki's my name I hope the
information you've been texting is legit
I don't like being played with guaranteed it's
the real deal assuming you brought that money
oh yeah no we got protocols right package first
you don't look like walk in with the money do you
bro of course not he really does look like Evan
Peters Bo over oh my God she's macgyvering her
foot she's going to put him on her hands whoa
she is Crafty they've given her a lot of time
to put something together she's making her
own Johnny [Music] Five the shots of her yes
like very pleased with her abilities this is
Herby Origins guys we're getting the
Fantastic Four robot she's building
it my have built this in a store room scr
nice that was great John that was
really guys thank you I I really
app please smash like And subscribe that's R
Us come on now don't I like that detail of the
glass just residing in shooting her with
bearings that's great oh my God this poor
woman she's not cut out for this no she's
earned it how you get jammed up like this
you got something to spill huh this guy's
having fun by Lopez Lopez who blew up the
Armory we're actually not at Liberty to say
until we get our money yep you're going to
get killed man I love the way he's playing that
too grasping for any threat of authority in this
situation God it looks like a saw trap
how about let's all go out and you show
me that one the cat brothers let's all go
out think he wants to go out take him out
oh boy oh dude dude yeah Evan Holbrook I
actually really love that detail thanks
again VY for the odd tip how he like jumped
and got shot like that result where is Maya
Lopez she's coming for you take them all out in
this yes bur to the witch SL first zombie in the
M oh I'm so
excited even this expression like she's
coming oh my God yeah the lighting in this
place was designed for a fight Batman and
Robin fights yes linoln Park music videos
can he fight I guarantee it I mean it looks
kind of like a Rob Zombie music video to be
fair with the needle
drop oo
nice bit of a slow motion to that yeah yeah he
can't have the Daredevil team on every fight
SC what why did you think little
Tiffany deserved to die make America SK
again [Music] ooh d Dam oh yes you are your
people interesting genetic memory
but with powers well I think it's
like mirror in the trajectory I
think it's both nice ah the pinball
machine that was cool ooh Legends of the
coyote whoa some jump frames are interesting
like a zap Zack Snider esque like zoom
out cool cool cool oh Cosmic
claw these overhead shots
settings she always looks like she's having like
a great time fighting yeah
she's always so happy after
yes nice got to the whip oh that's so good
beautiful it's like Jackie Chan with a horseshoe
I love seeing props use environmental props ski
ball oh use everything at your disposal oh my
God come on come on put his head through
the little hole with this a th000 points not
Bonnie mystical power [Music] time I haven't
heard this song In Forever it's going to be
Kingpin yep I have one eye I I I thought yeah
I understand I'm sorry I let me just nope
[Music] I love watching this guy let's go wow okay
leave my surate daughter alone yeah even from New
York there is a certain calibration to that Nick
of Time suspense you got to hit though and uh but
they didn't timing is is a little funky here and
there on on this show I think yeah but cool fight
I like how the fight distinguished itself from the
last fight yeah Rob Zombie got that Marvel money
[Music] yeah I do like the dynamic this
creates for her yeah we get to see her
open up some and they do see like sisters
like immediate oh the touch unless I need
to punch you for a diversion again I will hurt
you they will not hurt you I will hurt [Music]
you yeah I think they need to kill off Bonnie
the only thing that's keeping her human Bonnie
needs to get an Iron Man suit or something
or become a you know a special thing I they
need a fridge body part the part where we
were kidnapped by the guy who cleans my
skate
who do you think that was only one
person who could have and he has one
eye well you didn't shoot him in the face good
enough tonight things caught up to us both if the
offer still stands I'm helping still stands they
stand oh dude I really like him a lot that guy a
lot yeah he's great and she's opening up because
of these relationships in a way I hoped they would
that's why I wanted to hold back some of my yeah
because I feel like ma is so much more invested in
this episode also why it's a good binge like I do
feel like the model was good for this definitely
designed for a bench I think Disney's on the
right path here or the show's just complete
utter [__] according to what everyone said
before oh yeah those leaks from those incredible
source so lovely music c yeah oh my God we got
some mystical [__] for you that's cool it's
it's a McGuffin I love him so much he's great
you uh don't uh like it she doesn't know what it
is that means Chuck tushka is on the scene ooh if
you you uh don't uh like it I could paint it matte
black that that's the first time we've
really seen a full smile yeah is it yeah
she smirked but that was like a grin
that was a very real moment now as a
man I'm invested in her hey oh it's she
looked nicer if she smiled more just came
true yeah who that's cool chocked off
forever don't get in family business since
your uh grandmother and I not together no
more I still try to hump daily you won't go
see her yeah she does her heart is broken
when you let she left this place like
it was like a museum preserve you in
time yeah you're one to talk about reaching sounds
familiar there Maya I guess we all do things
we wish were different Disney's often saying the
same [Laughter] thing yeah that's why they reshoot
everything boy it's on a really good
path I think each episode has been
getting better yeah and its unique
voice is becoming more and more into
Focus man this shot so well God damn yeah it
doesn't feel like a product like it feels like
a show like there's so much like heart in you
could tell that people loved making it in a
really interesting way there is a passion behind
the camera here like the shots all have flourish
and Beauty yeah like they really utilizer
City and locations and I I do feel it feels
very much lived in the Cho to people of what
how they utilize it here in their story just
the way they spend time with and on them in
both small character moments and the big like
sweeping flashbacks like I just love that shot
of that grandmother just the difference between
shooting on location versus the volume but to
scale like this all feels like the difference
between like practical and having people that are
invested behind the camera on camera oh 1 million
per. mystical ending we a Fisk ending
a mystical Fisk ending I have one eye
oh she's in like superhero Garb now yeah Echo Red
look at them straps strapped up there
he is nail back like a I sensed his
[Music] presence I like the tune they compose for
him was that in Hawkeye or is this new I feel new
I think it's heavy it's strong just feels like
it's being played on a broken instrument yeah
oh come to Papa yes that was awesome I love the
boldness of Fisk showing up like that without
anyone else just him being enormous enormous in
such a vulnerable stage like she could just shoot
him in the other eye she want to and and she he
just comes up injured and like clearly hurt yeah
at a new outfit looking fresh with those drips oh
my man that was I really like this show kick up
pick up on the dialogue whoa what what dialogue
what do you have for me what the drips coin oh
we're on the drips do it John we're on the drips
you can't oh John just mocking what he does now do
what you naturally do I'm sorry I'm sorry hold on
hold on let me fix myself all right oh still mocks
it can't do it can't do it J can't do it natural
I was so wrapped up in the show I forgot the plug
that is oh it's like I'm looking at myself in the
mirror and I look great G re Nation shop.com get
this awesome shirt get that awesome shirt this
one this awesome shirt all designed by re real
reject couple in partnership with others but for
the most part design ourselves so thank you guys
so much cuz it is the personal most favorite
way to support the Chanel and I mean that from
the bottom of the heart thank you to all I bought
one uh you look good when you do it too and they
feel comfortable we make sure to chew shirts
that actually feel comfortable someone with
a hairy body I care about a comfortable shirt uh
what time is it we are up against the clock and
no one else's all right all right Coy seems like
you got a lot to say so we got two more episodes
to go through but Coy take it away brief because I
know we have more to go through uh I do think this
show is pce better than a lot of the Marvel shows
it feels like an early Marvel movie for me pacing
wise uh as far as trusting in the supporting
characters and letting the actual Universe
breathe I'm really enjoying some of the comic
elements where it feels like New York is just
over here causing all of this problem and it's
and it's like leaking into her town and that's
why I I sense like Kingpin was the next logical
thing to come to the town because now you've you
got to level up you've had the henchmen come to
the you have problem looming henchmen come to
the town Kingpin himself you have Kingpin stop
something coming there and then that's going to
escalate into the third Act of the show which
I feel like is what we're getting to now It's
Tricky with five episodes instead of six but I do
feel like we're approaching the third act now that
we've had the second act incident of the Bonnie
making her more humanized so I really do feel
like this is structured a lot like Series this
feels like a comic book six issue Arc or like
a trade paperback so it's really beautifully done
to not only make New York a character that's a for
boing element keeping the Kingpin and Daredevil
element over here but they're using the chronology
of years of TV and years of movies and all of
these elements of dared Kingpin to really build
out Ekko in a way where she feels independent and
New York feels independent simultaneously but she
like a good Avenger movie can pop in and out of
the main story so I'm I'm in love with the World
building they're doing here this feels a lot
more like genv versus the boys where it feels
like different perspectives in a universe that can
coexist and cohabitate a world by having it set in
Oklahoma so all of those elements plus the fight
choreography really leveling up not loving all the
editing around the fight there was a moment where
they had the fight end and they had to have time
pass they're like cut to ski ball and I was like
but overall what they've done is allow a world
to breathe in the way that I wanted the shows to
where you could build a character up on television
long form bring them into the movie and you'd care
about them if you've seen the show but you'd still
care about them in the movie and I think Ekko
being a a spotlight it being a darker show being
our rated does give me hope for Daredevil and
kinin going forward to allow that tone to have
Hell's Kitchen perhaps be R-rated have Deadpool
be R-rated have blade have Ghost Rider but that
doesn't sacrifice the stock price by having pg3
M so I really really was impressed yeah no I I
enjoyed this a lot too I like the progression very
much I I appreciate especially based on what we
said last episode that that was kind of Maya in
her element whereas this takes her into a place
where her element has bled over onto the people in
her life and is you know impossible to contain to
this like isolated operation and that is bringing
in just yeah more uh interesting character
interactions and stuff like that uh whether it
be with uh Bonnie or with Oh Black Crow uh them
teaming up finally after everything I thought was
really nice and like well earned and developed
and all that stuff and uh yeah The Supporting Cast
continues to be great and it's one of those things
where even when like I I appreciate something like
this in a constructive sense because yeah there
are times where like oh it's a bit of a funky
shot are like oh that was a weird cut but they
feel in line with you know actual people crafting
a Thing versus like oh this was just Frankenstein
together and that's why it feels weird it's like
okay yeah maybe you had to figure something out on
set or maybe something didn't go 100% as you hoped
it would but in a weird way it still felt pretty
unified within that and so yeah it's like even
with little Nicks and things I feel like yeah it's
only been kind of developing and progressing and
now I just hope that in these last two episodes
you know we can get a couple things that are
emotionally resonant in some kind of you know
particularly gripping or touching way to go along
with all the cool stuff and to make all the action
you know more meaningful because they have like
all the other stuff and I'm really again enjoying
the development and yeah if they can just continue
pushing those character beats to the Forefront
alongside all the other know cool stuff and like
especially having Wilson fist come back with that
you know that presence and that sense of like when
he calls the guys off that sends a message of its
own but for him to show up like I love the even
just the Nuance suggested by that of this guy who
is still very committed to his father figure role
in this person's life despite the mess of their
relationship here and now and I'm excited for I I
mean I could even see the next episode being like
kind of isolated to the two of them or something
which could be neat but uh but yeah I'm really
excited for whatever comes next to finish this
all off yeah I agree with both the things you guys
said hey you guys win yeah yes we win the whites
win it we win this review off oh God and the and
the film Styles too it's so pretty I I think this
Loki and like you mentioned what if those three
have really shown like a filmmaker you guys are
really great for letting me what you thinke I was
just commending you one of the things you I was
trying to throw that to you because you were so
enthralled at the of the episode with the whole
interlude and the and the film style I was trying
to I was trying to shovel past I was going to give
him another tangent but he didn't want my P up he
didn't want my te as you had said I I really
like the making and I'm going to keep cutting
you off because I'm colonizing your opinion Greg
it's okay it's okay guys just trying to get some
sympathy points is it working I'm so turnable
this is my you my sociopath com I've entered
sociopath entered sociopath here this is it right
here I will belittle or look for sympathy I will
Gaslight you in every possible way I can do it
we had a coming uh no what are you guys talking
about I don't know your turn the film Styles the
prologue I got nothing really to contribute now
stylistically mysticism it's okay guys it's okay
um well what I would add into the conversation mix
is the the representation of the chock top people
I I don't know what the proper words are to say
I'm always like every time I talk about some a a
a race of people or a culture of people that I am
not educated on always questioning am I saying
the right vocabulary to support my statements
here so I'm just going to hopefully everyone
recognizes my intention here in case I get a
word or two off here it's the engines okay is
it no this is definitely not that Nation chakon
Nation yeah he said Eng he did he did with that
hard J yep I N J us hard J proud of that joke
like that's great y AR J we got to remember
that funny um we got to remember that for the
next one yeah the next risky sical joke
about a whole nation of people best way
to use a joke is rep people kicked the
most throughout our country's history
a little more while they're we got a new
opportunity for ComEd can we profit a joke
off these people because they haven't suffered
enough this satire is important this is very
necessary this funny as like I knew J was just
making a joke love how he responded sincerely
when I said is it don't let that brilliant brilant
that's why camera is here that's why we do shows
together guys capture you have amazing maack fruit
throwing me like a very ridiculous request in like
the tone of your voice I'll be like sure I I guess
I'll entertain this this can only go well for me
I must have missed something I guess I'll take a
look anyway uh yeah like uh I I feel like the the
vibe of of uh of the Chaka Nation just literally
permeates throughout the entire presence of like
the voice of the show the voice of of the the the
look uh the mood that evokes from the just the
look and the atmosphere whether that be present
day or past it's kind of like the culmination of
past and present which is what the show is doing
from its um what would you call it like the pro
opening acts uh what are those called in the show
inst structurally I forget like like opening like
cold open or cold open yeah button or something
yes whatever it's called but yeah the cold open
before the credits Ru that section which usually
delves into the past of the chock to people and
then as we go through the present day story with
Maya Lopez and then but then you you're cutting
around to like her family and everyone and just
the like the people in Oklahoma of today I I think
that when they when they spoke about that with
being part of the representation of the show often
times when we talk about representation and being
included in there sometimes like the handling of
that is is usually feels repres ping yeah usually
it feels pandering we got one guy or or you could
feel a little bit of force like it it feels
completely natural here like it seems like the
intent of that is it's it feels like that is the
act like one of the actual purposes of the show
is to let that be part of the voice and and its
character and so I think the way they have been
executing that has been absolutely excellent and
it is one of the things that I gravitate towards
most when experiencing this show even when I
experience like certain shortcomings there is
that uniqueness that this show has that separates
itself from a lot of just television shows in
general you know like I'm gr gr there like some
other shows out there I haven't seen reservation
dogs which is not thean Nation you know uh but
there's you know it's it's not it's not like the
grittiest thing it's gritty for Marvel sure but so
I understand that uh so is it pushing boundaries I
don't know if it's like pushing boundaries but
it it feels more mature I would still say that
it's it definitely feels much more M this doesn't
feel like you're the one you sit down and watch
with the family nor has it necessarily gone to
VI to the point where I'm like wow this some of
the edgiest [__] seen nothing's got into like
Netflix terrain yet um it's like between Marvel
and Netflix it's like a nice radient honestly I
think like you freaking Ethan Hawk stepping on
glass Sho is still like more uh offputting than
anything else we've seen here so far right um
but that was like the opening of the show uh but
from what we've been getting so far yeah I think
it's been really strong and and if the lot of its
strengths I feel are outweighing it's uh things
that I might not particularly find to be as strong
I don't know if I'd call it a weakness per se like
there are are elements where I do feel like I
could be more like emotionally you're waiting for
it to transcend I'm I'm interested but I'm never
quite like truly moved or gripped you know like
at the end of day it's a moving picture at the end
of day it is supposed to be and that's the point
of Storytelling cuz there is a coldness which is
intentional um but I do love the things I'm loving
I'm really loving that's that's the thing about
it that that is outweighing some of the parts that
there normally this emotional experience thing
that I'm I'm touching on it's usually a massive
deterrence for me and it's not quite a mass of
deterrence for me here because there's so many
other things that's giving me that I'm really
liking a lot that I'm ating a different kind of
emotional experience from if that makes does that
make any sense what I'm trying to say yeah and and
anything that this is falling short on it's still
giving you a whole bunch of things that you can
point at and go like hey given some of the bumps
in the recent Marvel Road please continue going
down this direction instincts are good to follow
yeah I don't understand the the bad word of mouth
that came out before it because of the outweighing
of so much good well I could potentially see it
becoming a secret Invasion thing whereas where
it's like the poers get overwheling yeah I mean
like oh this is like really like serious and
focused I see you're saying but it's got nothing
the last couple episodes it starts to rush and
don't really give a [__] is Echo going to become
like overpowered with chakon nation mysticism
[__] by the end you know she kills King P like
how crazy is it going to get takes out Daredevil
he's obvious not going to kill Kingman he's in the
Daredevil show so and will there be a meaningful
use for the in like I like including all of the
history and all of the the the notes of the nation
and whatnot but is there going to be a personal
reason for doing that Beyond just explaining
a Celestial power set yeah that's cuz cuz yeah
like her there are moments where she seems like
she's opening up to when he gives her the the new
prosthetic leg and he makes a big deal out of like
this is representative of your culture part of me
was like well she's kind of detached from it and
maybe that could be part of her journey but uh but
yeah like it would be nice to be a little bit
more plugged into her personal journey through
these images and these you know flourishes of
history and I think we will hopefully if it lands
get there to the point where like those imagery
because a lot of the imagery in the Mac David Ma's
art with her is important like actual symbols tie
into the character a lot in the comic books so I'm
really hoping we get to the point where like a lot
of that imagery does come into play and I think
that the first thing I saw with that was like okay
this might be the connection between the imagery
and the character so I'm hoping that's where we
get and maybe that yeah maybe she doesn't get
imbued with like a complete cosmic power set but
maybe she has some attenuation to that and maybe
some ability to kind of tap into or harmonize with
it we should rap without Greg to be we should rap
without because I think we should before he gets
back the inmates taking over the Asylum leave a
like on the video we're done with this show before
he got back thanks guys your PCT the day shout
out Gabriel welcome to 2024 my friend W it is
uh January so I have to Fathom what your New
Year's resolution is going to be and if I know
you Gabriel and I think I do I think you do I
think I do it is to buy a b day oh I was going
to make a baptism joke but you beat me to it
baptize your bum my friend change your life with
with a nice jet of warm soothing cleansing water
because here's the thing Gabriel I need you to
be my guinea pig this year every time I go to
someone's house and then they want to show off
that like hey we got a bouet in here I'm always
like cool I have never used one cuz I don't get
how it works I don't understand where the water's
coming from where it's shooting from I don't get
how any of it works Gabriel my mind thinks that
it's just shooting up from the bottom of the
toilet of something that's been used already
and I'm like that's disgusting how is that that's
unhygienic I don't know what's happening there and
so Gabriel I'm going to need you to buy one tell
me what the process is like send video archive
footage if possible otherwise you're going
to get multiple angles you're going to get
a bunch of jokes about being an atheist again
or uh you know be being Angel Gabriel or some
[__] because you did not send me video footage
of how they were show us your butt we want to see
your butt and we want to see it your butt on a
bedet we want to see and and send us some of the
water too just you know once you're done with
it John please now we going to get demonetized
you're too graphically direct I'm sorry I mean you
know just you don't understand how to around these
bapti baptize your cheeks my friend pray pray
to this hygienic anyway happy New Year wash your
butt